[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo mi nombre es juliette real yo lo
saludo desde casa
[Música]
el tránsito hacia centroamérica desde
colombia es uno de los trayectos
terrestres más peligrosos para los
migrantes en el mundo el viaje hacia
panamá deben hacerlo a través de una
selva impenetrable bautizada como el
tapón del darién en lo corrido de este
año 17.000 personas lo han cruzado y al
menos 12 murieron en la frontera colombo
panameña según datos del ministerio de
seguridad de panamá
es una ruta que toman haitianos cubanos
pero es común encontrar también a
africanos y asiáticos transitar el
darién es la única forma posible de por
vía terrestre para llegar a panamá desde
colombia durante años la selva ha sido
escenario de tráfico de personas
asesinatos robos e incluso abusos
sexuales el flujo de migrantes bajó por
la pandemia pero volvió a activarse en
los últimos meses causando una crisis
humanitaria en la región organizaciones
de ayuda llegaron hasta allí para
atender las consecuencias del éxodo
médicos sin fronteras es una de las ong
que presta servicio en la región y
recientemente presentó un informe sobre
las impresiones de los miles de
emigrantes que atraviesan el darién
hablamos previamente con sergio martín
jefe de misión de médicos sin fronteras
para mexico y el proyecto del darién a
quien le consultamos sobre la realidad
que encontraron en las estaciones de
recepción migratoria
la realidad de los brillantes que
estamos viendo cada día es muy muy dura
llevamos casi diez años trabajando en
migración a lo largo de la ruta
migratoria y principalmente en méxico
donde las condiciones de violencia
contra los migrantes y de clandestinidad
son también muy fuertes pero aquí en
méxico en particular el tramo más
complicado que cada migrante nos narra
de aquellos que han atravesado el darién
es ese este es el darién es la selva
vemos muy grandes que salen de la selva
después de 8 o 10 días y bueno con
secuelas en su salud física en su salud
mental habiendo sufrido violencia
violencia física a violencia sexual
habiendo visto cómo mataban en algunos
casos a algunos de sus compañeros es un
tramo muy muy complicado del recorrido
es un tramo donde realmente pues no hay
seguridad para las personas migrantes y
lo que vemos es la foto más dantesca del
fenómeno migratorio en centroamérica sin
ningún lugar a dudas
uno de los aspectos más preocupantes del
informe es que en sólo quince días
médicos sin fronteras atendió 12 casos
de violencia sexual recientes así desde
estos casos de violencia sexual que
detectamos que atendemos a la salida de
la selva del darién en panamá son casos
de menos de 72 horas saben todos en
todos ellos estamos hablando de
violaciones en este tramo en el tramo de
la frontera entre colombia y panamá y en
este recorrido en particular que es un
recorrido que llega a abajo chiquito una
comunidad en panamá y todos estos casos
estos 12 casos si son de menos de 3 días
siempre van a haber ocurrido en este
tramo de frontera pero además de las
consecuencias físicas visibles de los
migrantes que cruzan el darién qué pasa
con las secuelas psicológicas que les ha
causado el éxodo esto nos explicó el
jefe de la misión de médicos sin
fronteras algunas de las personas que
atraviesan estamos dando de familias
estamos hablando de mujeres solas las
secuelas en la salud son enormes para
algunas de estas personas no podemos
olvidar que algunas de ellas
ya vienen huyendo de la violencia desde
sus lugares de origen y aquí en ciudad
de méxico por ejemplo en ciudad de
méxico tenemos un centro dedicado
exclusivamente para víctimas de tortura
y extrema violencia y en su mayoría son
personas migrantes son personas que han
sufrido tortura en origen o en tránsito
cuando hablamos de secuelas
en salud mental llegan al extremo de
hacer que la persona pierda su
funcionalidad son experiencias muy
fuertes y hay en algunos casos como digo
las personas van a arrastrar las
consecuencias de esta violencia sufrida
durante el resto de su vida
el gobierno de panamá asegura que
atiende las necesidades de los migrantes
bajo su estrategia de flujo controlado
sin embargo la realidad de los que
llegan al suelo panameño es otra
nosotros estamos trabajando en los
centros de recepción migratoria en
panamá las personas son privadas de
libertad las personas son dirigidas
hacia hacia otros centros y hacen
interior de panamá en estos centros son
bueno pues controladas digamos y ahí
estamos trabajando con el ministerio de
salud de panamá en este caso estamos
apoyando la respuesta a estos casos en
salud y en salud mental a estos casos
que están saliendo de la selva lo que sí
que pedimos encarecidamente al gobierno
panameño y al gobierno colombiano es que
aseguren una ruta segura y una ruta por
la que puedan transitar estas personas
esto no es el caso y estas violencias
que están ocurriendo están ocurriendo en
la frontera entre los dos países y es
porque hay tramos que no están
asegurados evidentemente es un lugar muy
inhóspito pero pensamos que puede haber
medios de que ambos gobiernos puedan
asegurar una ruta
más pacífica menos violenta para estas
personas el tránsito por el tapón del
darién durante los primeros meses del
año se debe principalmente a las
condiciones meteorológicas favorables
para internarse en la selva sin embargo
esto no les garantiza llegar a destino
seguro porque no sólo se enfrentan a
condiciones naturales sino delincuentes
que se aprovechan de su situación en el
camino hasta que inmigrantes de france24
recuerden comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
siguiendo más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]